the gyro can experience so what do you
do now Henry sudo say if you do decide
to not fight again you like I'm done I
did what I had to do I'm triple see two
world titles and let the gold medalist
my name is Etta in the history books
that's who you are I think I programmed
Joe to talk like that you see I'm an
analyst when I look if I look at you
completely objectively even if I didn't
know you and you're a great guy and I
always enjoyed talking to you
but if I didn't know you I'd be like the
[ __ ] like name someone who's
done more name someone who want two
world titles and a [ __ ] gold medal in
the Olympics and wrestling and did it
all in the most technical of divisions
yeah like I said so like this is like
I'm not seeing the best fighter in the
world because I'm not man there's I
would even put the me Chaz Johnson like
in front of me I would put a lot of
people in front of you know even though
I do have a win over him
but I wasn't the best wrestler in the
like I wasn't like the the greatest in
the in wrestling who knows an Olympic
champion like I fall into a very
secluded group but I'm one of a lot you
know but I think you think when you
collaborate both of my actors that I've
been in sports that's where the greatest
combat attitude of all time you know
comes in and it's a yeah and it's a
gimmick and I say it a lot but you know
part of it is a part of the gimmick is I
am telling the truth
yes you know what I'm saying like it is
a gimmick or not it's it's in the
conversation mm-hmm you're in the
conversation so maybe in the next 20
years though it's a conversation like I
don't know what they're like there's a
lot of people to think it should be GSP
and that's in the conversation is in the
conversation is one of the greatest of
all time some people say you guys must
have forgot how good Anderson Silva was
when he was in his prime that's true too
that's in the conversation too but you
are as well man you really are I mean
whether you you know whether you were
joking around about it or not you're in
the conversation is one of the greatest
combat sports athletes of all time and
there's a real good argument that when
you beat the guys who you be
particularly beating Demetrius Johnson
who is untouchable you know beating
Dominick Cruz the way you did which is
Dominick Cruz is always known for not
getting hit and you know you hit him and
you hit him a lot and then coming
back from the Marlin rice fight holy
[ __ ] after that first round to come back
and dominate him and just glue yourself
to him in the second and then put him
away [ __ ] man
I mean those are pretty pretty powerful
accomplishments yeah no doubt about it
no I appreciated you I appreciate and
don't though oh I think to answer your
question what's next is like there's a
quiz there's not only the Vulcan Oscar
fight that you know because he's and
he's not that he's not that much bigger
than me and I feel like man I know I
could beat him dude I just know it just
walk around about 150 150 abut it almost
it would have to it would be my skill
what you do to prepare for that would
you gain any weight or would you just
keep the body what you have with you
yeah I would try to give me be another
maybe five six pounds but I wouldn't
want to like I would try to do it as
natural as I possibly can
mmm used to have a little more mass but
that's a big jump yeah it does get
dangerous man at 45 yeah those 45 or
some of them are enormous you know yeah
but the other one is and this is
actually uh you know potential in the
talks like all he's gonna talk with Ryan
Garcia's manager of possibly making a
fight with yeah would Ryan Garcia Brian
Garcia the boxer the boxer you gonna box
why not to call me crazy
if things are now you know financially
and you know the cars are played right
yeah why not he he tweeted at me
he says you know he pretty much called
me out that's the way I took it tell
them as long as you can throw some leg
kicks in there you get three three leg
kicks around yeah
so it's been a lot that I've actually
been pretty busy like I was what that
was what Tyson knows we're at the aew
event and I was with them so there's
even a potentially even over to a IEW
and or the WWE and you were talking
about possibly boxing yeah possibly Ryan
Garcia man so it's that's just for a
giant payday yeah yeah obviously to win
obviously to fight what does he care
enough he's the boxers don't get as
crazy as we do you know I mean they
don't get crazy heavy but I'm walking
around 1/5
so if we do fighter probably at 35 which
is good I think dick McGregor and I
think McGregor's learning with with me
whether I think if Ryan wants to do it
and I think it's how much time would you
need to prepare for something like that
probably about two to three months to
about three months three months yeah and
like three months at least
[Applause]